physically I've been emotionally on my
mama Eric when it comes to being the
ideal Netflix star you fit the bill Noah
since naio your fans love you and
continue to support you by watching your
latest Netflix specials
you've starred in movies like the
perfect date Sierra Burgess is a loser
and to all the boys I've loved before
and now you're about to briefly leave
the Netflix world to film Charlie's
Angels we're curious to find out how old
you really are and whether or not you
have a girlfriend you would tell us the
truth right Noah we have the real ages
and relationships of 15 amazing Netflix
actors lined up for you so don't go
anywhere
keep watching to find out which famous
couple's son Millie Bobby Brown is
currently dating does your species like
M&Ms Joey King you probably know Joey
King as L Evans from the kissing booth
but that's just one of the Netflix
originals that she is starred in the 20
year old actress plays Morgan in life in
pieces as well as Greta grimly in Fargo
Joey used to date her kissing booth
co-star Jacob oh lordy but the couple
called it quits in April of 2019 after
two years of dating most recently Joey
has been spotted with the axe producer
Stephen Pete and they're rumoured to be
an item Lana Condor Laura Condor is well
known for playing Laura Jean in the hit
Netflix original film to all the boys
I've loved before the 22-year old
actress has been dating Anthony de
Latour since they first met at an Emmy
nomination event in 2015
Jacob oh lordy after calling it quits
with ex-girlfriend Joey King in April of
2019 Jacob was spotted vacationing with
his yuphoria co-stars India but despite
all the romantic rumors flying around
the couple has yet to confirm their
relationship the 22 year old Netflix
star is currently filming the kissing
booth - and fans are hoping that Jacob
and Joey will rekindle their
relationship shannon / sir Shannon
purser stole our hearts when she snagged
the role of Barbara Holland in stranger
things
Janan went on to become a big Netflix
star she
the supporting role in Riverdale while
starring in her very own rom-com Sierra
Burgess is a loser
Shannon is 22 years old she isn't dating
anyone at the moment
Natalie Dyer Natalie Dyer rose to fame
when she was cast as Nancy wheeler in
the hit Netflix original series stranger
things just like her character Nancy
Natalie fell in love with her on-screen
boyfriend Jonathan Byers played by actor
Charley Heaton in real life Natalie and
Charlie have been dating since 2016 just
like her co-star Shannon purser Natalie
is 22 years old Ross Lynch Ross Lynch is
a 23 year old former Disney Channel star
who quickly entered the Netflix database
he plays Harvey kinkle in the Chilean
Adventures of Sabrina I could never hate
you
but unlike Harvey Ross doesn't have eyes
for Sabrina Spellman in real life Ross
is currently dating his co-star jazz
Sinclair who is known for portraying
Rosalind Walker Katherine Langford
Katherine Langford was catapulted into
the limelight when she was cast as
Hannah Baker on the heart-wrenching
Netflix series 13 reasons why Katherine
is 23 years old and devoted to her
acting career despite being rumored to
have dated her co-star Ross Butler
Katherine appears to be single at the
moment Robert Sheehan if you're a fan of
Netflix the Umbrella Academy then Clause
Hargreaves might just be your favorite
character Klaus is portrayed by actor
Robert Sheehan who once starred as
Nathan young on misfits Robert is 31
years old and in case you're wondering
he's off the market Robert is dating
Jett trash co-star sofia boutella KJ
app' Kiwi actor KJ app' became an
international success when he landed the
role of Archie Andrews on the hit
Netflix series Riverdale KJ is 22 years
old and will do just about anything to
keep his private life a secret
KJ appears to be single at the moment
despite having been rumoured to be
dating his co-star on a dog's purpose
Britt Robertson debby ryan debby ryan
became a household name at a very young
age due to her success on the disney
channel but after leaving disney debbie
was welcomed into Netflix's repertoire
she now stars
paty Bledel on the controversial series
insatiable I might be skinny on the
outside but on the inside I'm still
fatty patty debbie is 26 years old and
currently engaged to her longtime
boyfriend Josh Dunn who makes up one
half of the musical duo twenty one
pilots Millie Bobby Brown Millie may
only be 15 years old but that's never
stopped her from following her heart the
stranger things star is reportedly
dating
Romeo Beckham the son of David and
Victoria Beckham Millie may have a busy
schedule but she's never too busy for
Romeo
Alex Laufer Alex loether received his
breakthrough role when he snagged the
part of young Alan Turing in the
imitation game Alex went on to star in
the Netflix series the end of the effing
world where he quickly became a fan
favorite Alex is 24 years old and
currently single he's rumored to be part
of the LGBTQ community Dillon Manette's
Dillon Manette is known for starring as
clay Jensen on Netflix is 13 reasons why
did I kill Hannah Baker the 22 year old
actor recently revealed that he has a
new woman in his life
Dylan is dating Lydia Knight the lead
singer of the regrets Ali Wong 37 year
old comedian and actress Ali Wong is a
Netflix star through and through she
starred as Sascha Tran and the rom-com
always be my maybe Ali husband married
to Justin hakuta since 2014 noah
Santonio noah has made it big as a
Netflix star the 23 year old actor
snagged the hearts of millions when he
first appeared as Peter into all the
boys I've loved before Noah recently
started dating model alexis friend and
he seems completely smitten by her who
is your favorite netflix actor tell us
in the comments thanks for tuning in
subscribe to the things and give this
video a big thumbs up we'll see you next
time
[Music]